everybody likes free games and  PlayStation Plus gives them to us every  month and now we know what we're getting  in July I'm Tony this is a game spot  news update and this is your PlayStation  Plus lineup ps4 owners are getting  saints rose standalone DLC gat out of  hell and the brand new brawler fury ps3  owners are getting Western shooter call  of juarez bound in blood and the last  generation classic fat princess coming  to the PS Vita are the RPG or ishika  tainted blood lines and prince of persia  revelations a remake of warrior within  any of those sound good to you the next  batch of free PS plus games will be  available when the store refreshes on  Tuesday July fifth for now you can still  grab some of last month's games like NBA  2k16 and gone home and if you're looking  for the best way to keep up with all the  latest from PlayStation you're already  in the right place